good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm trey gowdy
yet another woman has come forward to
accuse new york governor andrew cuomo
of sexual misconduct and harassment
the number is now up to seven seven
women have made allegations
and finally two top new york democrats
senator chuck schumer
and kirsten gillibrand are calling on
him to resign
and yes yes i know what you're thinking
is that the same
kirsten gillibrand who believed a single
witness before the witness even said a
word when it came to brett kavanaugh
and now it takes seven allegations for
her to speak out against cuomo
but the governor doesn't care what they
think he says he's not going anywhere
listen to this
politicians who don't know a single
fact but yet form
a conclusion and an opinion
are in my opinion reckless and dangerous
that my friends is politics at its worst
politicians take positions for all sorts
of reasons
including political expediency and
bowing
the pressure people know the difference
between playing politics bowing to
cancel
culture and the truth i'm not going to
resign
it's eye-opening to go back and read
what the media and other democrats were
saying about andrew cuomo
eight to ten months ago they were giving
him awards they wanted him to be
president they wanted him to be
vice president they wanted him to be the
attorney general for the united states
what's also highly relevant when you
think about it is this
most of these allegations now seven
allegations of sexual impropriety
harassment misconduct
battery oppression they existed then
most of these allegations existed or the
factual basis to support them
existed while the media was heaping
praise on cuomo
to be sure the media will say but but we
didn't know
we weren't aware to which we'll respond
why not
why didn't you know i thought your job
was to tell us what we don't already
know i thought you were investigative
journalists
i thought democracy died in darkness and
you were the light
i thought you spoke truth to power
i thought you were all the news that fit
to print
well that was fit to print back then too
i think the media didn't find these
allegations last spring and summer while
they were
lavishing praise on andrew cuomo in
large part
because they never looked for it and
that's why the media
aren't taken seriously anymore their
investigative journalism
is only in high gear when it comes to
republicans or people
they don't like their dogged pursuit of
the truth
took a vacation so they could swoon over
their
preferred political candidates but
praise the lord
i've been wondering for months what it
would take
for the new york times and the
washington post and kamala harris and
alexandria ocasio-cortez and jerry
nadler
and others to finally call for cuomo's
resignation
i've been wondering how much will be
enough for them
how long will it be before they admit
they didn't do their jobs how long must
we wait for even the
slightest acknowledgement that the
person they wanted to be the president
the vice president the attorney general
of the united states
had a long history of abusing women and
the answer is
it takes seven seven allegations is the
threshold for these democrats
seven three or four well we're not quite
ready to make the call yet
five well we're getting close but but
let's keep an open mind but
seven dog on it we draw the light at
seven our principles dictate that we
really get serious about this when the
seventh
different woman alleges abuse or
criminality
you know the people in the media wonder
why republicans think the media are
biased and in the tank for democrats
oh i don't know let me think about that
for a second maybe because the media
are biased and in the tank for democrats
democracy dies in darkness you say
the washington post mission statement
actually makes me laugh
not the concept the hypocrisy if you
really think we believe you're the light
the objective neutral detached
light that makes me laugh you can't even
find a light switch
because you were too busy promoting
andrew cuomo for higher office
so don't ever lecture us on democracy
and the light